bonsoir stéphanie milot alors ce qui
vous intéresse c'est justement c'est ce
vécu le parcours de ces personnes alors
premier constat il n'ya pas un profil
type de malades en revanche la majorité
a négligé le dépistage et minimiser les
premiers symptômes c'est bien ça
bonsoir oui alors je travaille j'ai
proposé mes compétences au chu pour
faire un travail
auprès des patients et des soignants et
donc je fais des entretiens avec les
personnes hospitalisées qui ont donc
développé des formes sévères est ce
qu'on peut ce qu'on peut d'emblée
constater c'est que ces personnes ont
très souvent initialement premiers
symptômes penser qu'elle s'était
refroidie et donc elles ont identifié
plus tôt un refroidissement n'ont pas
forcément pensé au co vide sur cette
base elle ont pris d'été pour soigner
leurs prêts le refroidissement pendant
un jour deux jours parfois trois jours
ce qui n'a pas forcément de ce qui n'a
pas donné lieu à un amélioration et
elles ont éventuellement commencer à
penser que ça pouvait être le co vide et
à partir de ce moment là elles sont
allées chercher sur les réseaux sociaux
des recettes avec des rimes et d'asier
avec des suppléments les supplémentation
alimentaire elles ont pris des vitamines
c des vitamines des parfois du zinc
parfois de l'herbe à pic et non pas vu
forcément d'amélioration puisque c'était
personnes qui souvent ont des
comorbidités et se sont retrouvés dans
un état assez dégradé au bout de
plusieurs jours au bout de six jours et
qui ont fait que l on appelait les
secours en état d'urgence et de
dégradation alors c'est déjà une île aux
trésors leur cour je vais mettre ça
justement n'est pas une évidence pour
ces personnes selon vous
parce que parce que les personnes ont
suivi ce qu'il ya sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'elles ont cru que le recours
à la pharmacopée à la pharmacopée locale
les aider et qu'elles ont perdu des
jours de prise en charge et eu un retard
au diagnostic un retard à la prise en
charge parfois c'est aussi parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de médecin traitant
et elles ne se sont pas perçus elle même
comme étant des personnes à risque donc
elles arrivent très dégradée ce qui
diminue leur chance de survie par
rapport à la rapport aux qu'ovide et à
la maladie autre élément qui ressort de
cette étude qui est toujours en cours 1
je le rappelle c'est une colère de ces
malades il regrette pour beaucoup leur
négligence
alors moi je parlerais pas de négligence
suis désolé c'est par un terme plus
j'utilise
les certains patients quand on leur
demande quelle était leur position par
rapport au vaccin pour certains ils
restent réfractaires mais la majorité
comme moi j'ai rencontrés et ont exprimé
de la colère ils sont en colère contre
le fait que les réseaux sociaux ont
diffusé des intox des faits que news des
informations fausses sur ce qui se passe
au chu des informations fausses
concernant la pandémie ils sont en
colère de s'être laissée influencer de
s'être laissé berner que les couleurs
mentir sur la réalité en minimisant
l'épidémie en disant que c'était de la
dengue ou autre chose ils sont en colère
de ne pas s'être fait vacciner ils sont
en colère d'avoir mis leur santé en
danger parce que ils ont suivi des
bêtises et ils ont suivi des gens qui
les ont influencés et cette colère ali
profonde parce que c'est des gens c'est
des gens qui savent que leur vie est en
danger et qui vont éventuellement perdre
leur vie et je voudrais faire référence
à un patient que j'ai rencontré cette
semaine de 36 ans qui justement disait
que il s'en voulait lui même et j'ai
essayé de le de le convaincre de ne pas
s'en vouloir à lui même mais qu'il s'en
voulait de ne pas de ne pas avoir été
plus rapidement à ne pas avoir été
rapidement se faire vacciner et ce
monsieur disait qu'il avait une famille
qu'il aimait sa famille qu'il avait des
enfants qu'ils voulaient vivre qu'il
avait recommencé à faire construire sa
maison qu'il avait une entreprise et qu'
il était dans la vie à 36 ans et j'ai
appris son décès aujourd'hui stéphanie
muzard alors où j'ai de suite et fanions
boulot on va conclure mais en clair
personne en fait n'a intégré la
nécessité des tests ou ont recours en
tout cas à l'avis d'un médecin que l'on
soit pour ou contre la vaccination c'est
ce qui doit alerter selon vous
je pense que c'est qu'on peut pas dire
personne mais je pense qu'il ya aussi un
problème c'est que les gens ne se sont
pas perçus comme étant des personnes à
risque et ça aussi c'est important les
gens qui ont de l'attention des gens qui
font du diabète des gens qui sont en
surpoids ou obésité sont concernés plus
particulièrement par ce virus et le
problème c'est qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément perçu ce risque ils n'ont pas
forcément non plus une impression qu'il
prenait des risques parce que souvent
par exemple pour les adultes y sont
contaminées dans la famille parfois par
des jeunes qui eux ont été contaminées
dans des fêtes et du coup il ya un
problème sur la perception du risque et
moi je voudrais dire que ces personnes
qui sont particulièrement vulnérables
il est important que dès les premiers
symptômes elle consulte un médecin où
elle aille faire un test et que la
conscience que nous sommes tous
concernés augmente face à la situation
assez catastrophique que nous vivons
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup c'était fadil
hulot d'avoir accepté de nous parler ce
soir sont épuisés
merci merci c'est fanny mouloud avoir
accepté de nous parler ce soir de cette
étude que vous menez en ce moment sur
cette crise du coc vide aux côtés des
patients hospitalisés mais également aux
côtés des soignants merci encore